Це водосховище дає Кейптауну майже половину всієї питної води.
У 2015-му значні посухи призвели до того, що дамба почала висихати.
На супутникових знімках можна побачити, як з кожним місяцем запасів води стає чимраз менше.
У 2018-му Кейптаун наблизився до так званого "нульового дня"
"День нуль"
День, коли вода більше не тече з крана і люди мусять стояти за нею у черзі.
Кейптаун став першим великим містом, в якому закінчилися запаси води.
Першим, але не останнім.
Джакарта, Лондон, Пекін, Токіо - в усіх цих містах може настати такий "нульовий день" вже в найближчі десятиліття.
У більшості частин світу населення щонайменше один місяць на рік стикається з нестачею води.
Різниця між пропозицією води та попитом на неї дедалі зменшується.
Але як таке може бути?
Наша блакитна планета майже повністю покрита водою. Точніше - води на Землі більше одного мільярда трильйонів літрів.
Проблема полягає в тому, що 97% води на землі - солона. А більша частина прісної води заморожена в льодовиках.
Менше 1% води на землі є питною. Ось чому багато хто вважає найкращим вирішенням водної кризи - опріснення.
Опріснення морської води здається дуже простим рішенням: ви берете непитну солону воду, видаляєте з неї сіль, і отримуєте необмежений запас прісної води.
Чому ж ми тоді не будуємо більше установок для опріснення води?
Опріснення моря - природний процес, відомий вже тисячі років.
Як зазначав Аристотель, сонце перетворює морську воду в пару, яка потім конденсується і падає назад у вигляді дощу.
Його земляки швидко опанували цю технологію.
Грецькі моряки кип’ятили морську воду для тривалих подорожей.
Римляни використовували глиняні фільтри для відокремлення солі.
Ці два основні принципи діють і сьогодні.
Термічне опріснення використовує тепло. Температура кипіння солі набагато вища, ніж води.
Отже, коли ви кип’ятите солону воду, випаровується лише прісна вода. Сіль залишається.
Метод мембрани використовує для опріснення тиск.
Солона вода - тут для зрозумілості пофарбована в червоний колір - пресується через мембрану.
Прісна вода - тут позначена блакитним кольором - проходить крізь мембрану. А сіль затримується по інший бік.
Лише у 19-му столітті, коли індустріалізація та зростання чисельності населення дали поштовх науковим дослідженням, технологію суттєво вдосконалили.
Збільшення населення - головна причина дедалі гострішого дефіциту води.
Манзур Кадір є дослідником довкілля та водних ресурсів із 30-річним досвідом.
У регіоні Близького Сходу та Північної Африки, наприклад, живе близько 5 відсотків світового населення,
але тут лише 1 відсоток глобальних водних ресурсів.
Незабаром один фактор може зробити опріснення води ще більш важливим:
глобальне потепління.
Через потепління клімату дедалі більше води випаровується.
А, як зазначав Аристотель, більше водяної пари означає більше хмар, що призводить до більшої кількості дощів.
Але дощ не випадає рівномірно. На цій карті показано, як змінюються опади в ході глобального потепління.
У фіолетових регіонах буде випадати більше дощів, у помаранчевих - менше.
Тепер порівняйте це з цією картою. Червоним позначено регіони, в яких сьогодні недостатньо води.
У посушливих районах, таких як Близький Схід та Каліфорнія, буде випадати ще менше опадів.
В інших країнах, таких як Індія, буде більше дощів у сезон мусонів, але менше в посушливий період, коли дощі так потрібні людям.
Попит на воду зростає дуже стрімко. Ще від кінця 80-х - 90-х. Але особливо пришвидшилася ця динаміка в останні двадцять років.
Едвард Джонс - дослідник, який нещодавно зробив аналіз стану опріснення світового океану.
На сьогодні ми маємо близько 16 000 опріснювальних установок, які виробляють близько тисячі кубометрів води на добу.
Але придивіться ближче до цієї карти.
Якщо поглянути на те, скільки знесоленої води ми у світі виробляємо, то наразі 71% виробляється в країнах з високим рівнем доходу.
Це пов'язано з високими витратами на опріснення моря.
Щоб кип’ятити мільярди літрів води, потрібно багато енергії.
На Близькому Сході доступність викопного палива робить теплові процедури дешевшими, але для інших типів це може бути в 25-30 разів дорожче.
Однак не обов'язково енергія має надходити від викопного палива.
Стартап у Берліні пропонує стійку альтернативу.
Мене звати Алі Аль-Хакім, я співзасновник і генеральний директор Boreal Light. Я переїхав до Берліна із Західної Німеччини.
Дайте мені випити склянку води.
Хочете чого-небудь випити?
Вашої води?
Якщо бажаєте.
Так, будь-ласка!
Отже, вода надходить у систему зі свердловини. Потім вона проходить крізь насос-підсилювач.
Вода притискається до мембран під тиском 40 бар, коли сіль відділяється від води. Це чиста, опріснена вода, з чистою енергією.
Зелена енергія - запорука успіху компанії. Ось один з її заводів у Кенії.
Ці сонячні батареї знижують витрати на воду в тих селах, де немає електрики.
Ми отримуємо воду та електроенергію завдяки сонцю та вітру безкоштовно, тож тепер ми можемо виробляти тисячу літрів за п’ятдесят центів.
Ця ціна може скласти конкуренцію чистій воді з річок або свердловин.
Але є ще одна проблема.
Що робити з ось ЦІЄЮ водою?
Ми витіснили всю цю сіль з води, щоб отримати нашу прісну воду.
Але сіль все ще міститься у нашому розчині, просто в меншому обсязі, тому ця вода більш солона.
Ця вода - це так званий розсіл.
У глобальних масштабах ми виробляємо більше розсолу, ніж опрісненої води.
Із установки для опріснення трубою виходить гіперсалінова вода. Коли вона витікає, то опускається на дно, бо вона щільніша.
Солоність і температура також можуть зменшити рівень кисню у воді.
Це насправді саме те, що завдає більшої шкоди організмам: нестача кисню. В основному вони задихаються.
Розсіл також може містити хімічні речовини, які можуть завдати шкоди морській флорі й фауні.
Галузі потрібна краща стратегія боротьби з цим розсолом.
Ми виробляємо дедалі більше відходів без плану утилізації.
Але що, якби ці відходи могли стати ресурсом?
Помідори, водорості та певні види риби можуть переносити високий вміст солі.
Boreal Lights використовує розсіл для вирощування їх у таких ваннах.
Існує можливість вилучення солі та металу.
Вже існують технології подальшого використання розсолу, але в дуже малому масштабі.
Завдання полягає у застосуванні цих технологій у великих масштабах.
Отже, чарівної формули опріснення не існує.
Цей процес має стати більш ефективним, перш ніж країни з низьким рівнем доходу зможуть його собі дозволити.
Установки слід переобладнати з використання викопного палива на відновлювані джерела енергії, щоб зменшити шкідливі викиди.
Також всій галузі потрібно розробити план боротьби з розсолом.
Але такі установки вже є життєво важливими для багатьох громад.
Дуже важливо усвідомити, що опріснення морської води буде використовуватися в майбутньому.
Тож нам необхідно працювати над вирішенням проблем, пов'язаних з опрісненням.
Це поступовий процес, він не станеться за одну ніч. Але я помічаю, що є готовність використати потенціал опрісненої води.
Нині у Кейптауні ситуація набагато краща, а водосховище наповнене.
Місто швидко збудувало установки для опріснення, щоб уникнути "нульового дня".
Але рішенням кризи стало не опріснення води і не будь-яка інша технологія.
Нікому не можна приймати душ більш ніж двічі на тиждень.
Я можу митися в душі лише 2 хвилини.
Змивайте, лише якщо змивати необхідно.
Ми дуже старалися витрачати якомога менше.
Ви мусите економити воду так, наче це питання життя і смерті.
Громадяни ПАР почали ставитися до води більш свідомо.
Ми ставимось до води ощадливо.
Намагаємося щосили економити воду.
Вони сприймають воду як життєво необхідний, незамінний ресурс.